hey I'm Jake Borelli I'm Niko - OH and
we're the cast of the thing about Harry
we're here to take the quiz are you more
Sam or Harry from the thing about Harry
what do you think you are I'm Harry
I'm definitely Sam well see first how
would your BFFs describe you let's see
we have smart ambitious charming loyal
impulsive funny yeah like I was loyal
but uh and funny I guess not I'm gonna
say smart even though that kind of
sounds douchey yeah okay pick your
favorite school subject English history
science art foreign language and math
definitely art yeah which trivia
category would you be best at Harry
Potter huh yes yeah
general knowledge probably high like in
World War two history Shakespearean
literature music from the nineteen
sixties definitely and Friends we just
become a safe person what if we're just
like right in the middle well pick a TV
couple Callie and Arizona for a reason
Adam II heard of it heard of it Magnus
and Alec from Shadowhunters oh they're
both cute so Willow and Tara from Buffy
the Vampire Slayer Ian and Mickey from
shameless Cheryl and Tony from Riverdale
and Patrick and David from shits Creek I
gotta pick my own girls Callie in
Arizona 11 years you have biggest
lesbian relationship in the world it's
got to be them yeah no I feel oh man
I like I like Riverdale so maybe yeah
I'll go with Riverdale
Carolyn Tony okay choose a song to add
to your road trip playlists party in the
usa' sucker come on Eileen huh single
ladies don't stop believin
guy Oh filthy party automatic just
because it's like fun and okay yeah I'm
gonna go don't stop believe it
okay yeah that's it that's a classic
what's your ideal first date go into the
movie a picnic in the park cooking
dinner together mini golfing a romantic
boat ride and grabbing drinks and
talking all night I'm gonna do cooking
dinner together but that means me
watching him cook dinner Oh actually
romantic boat right yeah yeah that's
just I've done that that's very nice and
finally pick a rom-com the thing about
Harry the thing about Harry the thing
about here no we got okay When Harry Met
Sally Bridget Jones diary to all the
boys I've loved before crazy rich Asians
13 going on 30 and say anything honestly
I loved crazy rich Asians yeah no no I
really liked it and I also feel like
it's like a like a new spin on the
rom-com which is so in right now
yeah um oh I just saw it I saw what I
don't have not um I'm gonna say say
anything I love that contentiously yeah
you guys we're both Sam haha
look at that I don't know if you're
allowed to see the screen but there it
is yeah
cuz when that's hard to get Harry know
who and I know that you got the best one
I feel great I was I was expecting it
just because you know I'm uh pretty much
Sam through and through but I thought
maybe party in the usa' might skew me
the other way but you know we got it
it's great yeah I'm not feeling good
funny yeah thanks for taking the test
with us guys as you know we had a blast
check it out and watch our movie the
thing about Harry on freeform maybe
you'll have better luck
hurry or you can just be lucky in
kissing
[Music]